[Music]
good morning Hank it's Friday Hank
that's the view outside of my backyard
the view that I'm generally looking at
while I'm writing as you know Hank I've
never taken a lot of stock in nature I
mean I'm in favor of the environment and
everything but my general policy is that
we should protect it by keeping
ourselves distant from it
I'm generally a big fan of inside in
fact I believe that the entire reason
human beings created inside was so that
we wouldn't have to deal with outside
anymore
and I've always found it endlessly
amusing that people choose to be outside
camping backpacking when our ancestors
went through all this trouble to make
inside for our comfort and happiness
going outside just seems dismissive to
your ancestors let's face it Hank nanny
and pawpaw worked hard their whole lives
so that we could live inside but ever
since I moved to Indiana I find my
distaste for outside kind of beginning
to wane in fact Hank I am so enamored
with outside that I am now going to show
you a nature themed nerdfighters photo
remember nerdfighters SPF 30 or above
that's right baby we may be pasty but
nerdfighters can hang out at the beach I
mean I still don't like the occupants of
outside for instance I don't like mice
and I don't like moles there's a family
of raccoons that lives under our deck I
don't like the raccoons but I am
starting to enjoy working outside
although it's a screened-in porch so
it's only kind of half outside
in fact tank maybe screened-in is the
exact right amount of outside it occurs
to me that I could probably hike the
Appalachian Trail as long as I had a
screened-in enclosure around me at all
times
Hank I'm looking forward to doing my
punishment on Tuesday I've already
gotten some medals of some kind together
and this weekend I'm gonna get myself to
the thrift store give me some big baggy
pants maybe one of those old belts like
I used to have some green hairspray oh
speaking of the green hairspray
obviously I don't want you to just
spray-paint a green mohawk into your
head I want you to spray-paint a green
mohawk into your head and recreate the
goth picture okay Hank I'm gonna go back
inside and continue my attempt to find
the perfect song to dance to during my
punishment I mean obviously if you're
going to be a
surprisingly fat guy recreating the look
of a shirtless amazingly skinny guy you
need a great song incidentally anyone
with suggestions for that song is
welcome to share them with me Hank I'll
see you on Monday